لم يكن نزوله هذا حين اعلن الترشحه اول
مره الا بدايه صعود بعدها اصبح زعيما بلا
منازع للحزب الجمهوري ويتمتع بقاعده
مناصرين ولاؤها مطلق لا تحركه زلات لسانه
وما يحيضه من فضائح وقضايا وتحقيقات حتى
اصبح هذا الولاء ظاهره احتار فيها كثير في
هذا المطعم الصغير في ضواحي مدينه اتلانتا
عاصمه ولايه جورجيا التقينا بمجموعه من
انصار الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لاستكشف
معهم اسباب ولائهم له
هما الان يصورون انصار ترامب والماغا
بانهم عنصريون لسنا كذلك ماذا تعني جعل
امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى نحن نود رؤيه
امريكا تعود لما كانت عليه عندما كان
اجدادنا على قيد الحياه
عندما كان اجدادي على قيد الحياه كانت
هناك قيم نشانا عليها
عندما رشح ترامب نفسه اول مره لم اكن من
المعجبين به لكن ذلك تغير عندما سمعت
كلامه عن العوده الى ما كنا عليه ما يطمح
له الجميع هو اشياء مثل القدره على امتلاك
منزل والعيش بمستوى ما نبذوله من عمل ما
تفعله الحكومه الان هو جبايه مزيد من
الضرائب ولم يتبقى للبسطاء شيء
لكنه هموم بنك العيش والحنين للماضي الذي
سمعناه من هؤلاء ليس وحده العامل الذي
يشكل لتربيه السياسيه
هناك بعد ديني العقائدي المحافظ متمثل في
الطائفه الانجيليه احدى اهم واكبر الطوائف
المسيحيه في البلاد والتي يؤيد غالبيه
رهبانها ومرتديها الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب ويشكلون جانبيه من بين انصبه
للانجيين ما يهمهم هو ان يتبنى اولوياتهم
لذلك فانه منذ 2016 اتمنى رؤيتهم للعالم
من مواقفه معاديه للاجهاض والزواج
المثليين كما يرون في ترامب نبؤاتهم مروعه
لنهايه العالم المتمثله في معركه كبرى بين
الخير والشر ومن وجهه نظرهم ترامب هو من
سيقودهم فيها
لكن البعدين المعيشي والدين وحدهما لا
يشكلان صوره كامله لتيارغا كما تسمى حركه
ترامب فيميزها ايضا تبنيها وايمانها
بنظريات المؤامره التي تروج بينهم وتساهم
بشكل كبير في صناعه توجهاتهم السياسيه من
بين ابرز تلك النظريات ايمانهم بوجود مجلس
حكم عالمي خفي يتحكم في مصائر الشعوب او
ان الديمقراطيين يتاجرون بالاطفال
ويشربون دماءهم واخرها كانت مزاعم تزوير
الانتخابات
هو احد الجمهوريين المعارضين لترامب
وحركته هو يرى ان النظريات المؤامره ليست
ظاهره عرضيه بين انصاره بل هي استراتيجيه
ينتجها ترامب ومساعده
دونالد ترامب ومساعده الببغاوات ينشرون
الاكاذيب ويرددونها لتنتشر اولا في
الاعلام فيصدقها الملايين من انصاره
اكاذيب مثل ان الديمقراطيين يتاجرون في
تهريب الاطفال بذلك هم يعززون من انعدام
الثقه في الطرف المقابل ولا يتركون لانصار
ترامب مجالا سوى الاستمرار في دعمه هي
استراتيجيه طبقوها بنجاح للاستمرار في جمع
التبرعات من المناصره والحفاظ على ولائهم
له هو مزيج من بنك العيش والحنين الى
الماضي وابعاد دينيه
فضلا عما التافه حولها من حركات يمينيه
المتطرفه واخرى تؤمن بتفوق العرق الابيض
ظاهره باتت الان لاعبا اساسيا ويخشى
خصومها من ان تكون ان حكمت مره اخرى نهايه
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه احمد هزيم الجزيره
اصلا